planes Nuala oops no this one yeah it's
a King Finian player let's be quick
about it Queenie 86 rare p5 is normally
played okay i just i just read it like
nothing happened
92 less prone to h6 first surprise that
you try the King minionese this kind of
London system player who never never
does any active move and now you place
the King linnean some really surprising
anyway I usually have black against I
couldn't even tell what he usually does
some let's see what happens here I'm
happy to trade this piece Bishop
understand is always potentially
dangerous journey I think a form i want
to play at four fixes pawns there on
dark squares Aaron light cliff sorry
obviously on light squared + 5 is a
light square okay so this is
strategically very nice for white why is
he going there I can push it back okay
and now even Queen deform it can be
played to centralize the Queen and
looking at a seventh is a bit awkward
here for black
can even think of c-5 shortly and this
threaten c6 yes I expected that it is
probably also the right decisions as the
Queen was so strong one deform so here
the time the G form is going to be
strong I can probably repair it
immediately why does that work Jake no
that does not work this should take this
be five pawn takes sc5
so we should see for strong
on night a force also a good move I
think I do that
and it was not as bad as it looked I
mean it looked completely terrible with
some of the game continues the gun
doesn't help on that much
is until all that much
well now what did I do wrong it should
be really better than the solution I
mean why it is better here but it looked
absolutely terrible does this c 6 move
it's good yeah I've 93 and if he takes
the ending will be very nice and I have
to threaten night before so we have to
take almost after 93
[Music]
ok
you
already very nice but when I get in G
form that i will definitely do cannot
take 493 cuz of 94 and yeah I basically
has to do this so take it and then we
need winning this portion ask this one
winning c6
time learning any threat see I don't see
it dominating the night pretty badly
I asked to go back somehow with this
piece 960 what is the deal I want them
all all the porns check
ok now that actually doesn't matter all
that much it was kind of unnecessary
this move ok 96 I was really unnecessary
[Music]
check we've had a much easier life down
check check check okay check checkmate
ok so let's have a look at this it was a
pretty neat opening result so let's see
you create is an unusual move here and
i'll probably be assured you five isn't
the best rip slyme I don't know the
immediate night h5 is not great because
of g3 may I can't probably just castle
or something but ok let's have a look at
the actual game h5 takes it yeah this is
this is looking quite nice yeah this is
very much comparable to a line of the h3
king's indian but here i have not played
h3 with more useful move Bishop e2 yeah
this is a position that I definitely
think should be slightly better for wild
and okay f 494 okay no that was not
something
how about black is some willing is pawn
structure here but probably this is no
good here because of this there's
something like that is a sector so 94
was the problem with this move oil can
x5 is just a bamboo might be five given
by the engine 494 not bad but this is
also difficult i'm a seven is always
attacked and jung yeah that's
understandable yet but the ending is of
course nya say i was just a bit
frustrated that this wasn't even worse
then it will die in it it looks terrible
but somehow black holds on him and
continues we should see form was better
ed looks no more more obvious but I
wasn't quite sure what the dealers and
this one and then just attack it but ok
let that make sense and it's stronger
than what I did so that was the way to
really read it I mean this way that was
comfortable but nothing nothing
brilliant cannabis this is not fun to
play in this position but could gone bad
after this again with chief one
okay yeah this is a winning ending I
just made it extremely i played this a
little bit little bit weird check here
here I don't know what I was thinking
with Ruby 6 that doesn't make any sense
I can just take a seven okay I mean the
position is so good that you cannot
really spoil it completely open should
be seven when a young but I had seen
that he cannot read it revenge
appreciate in any meaningful way and
this is also an easy win ok guys thanks
for watching